[Musique]
pourquoi on a choisi Tik Tok parce que
cette plateforme a plusieurs
spécificités c'est celle qui s'adresse
de très loin le plus aux adolescents et
aux enfants son algorithme est
extrêmement addictif et un algorithme
addictif vis-à-vis d'un public fragile
que sont les adolescents et les enfants
évidemment ça pose des problèmes
[Musique]
aussi la possibilité d'aller étudier on
va dire sur pièce un certain nombre
d'éléments si jamais le travail de la
commission le requiert se focaliser sur
trois points principaux le premier c'est
celui de des retentissements
psychologiques de la santé mentale du
développement cognitif des enfants et
des adolescents le deuxième c'est le
problème du transfert de données et puis
le troisième point porte sur le contenu
ou sur le non contenu est-ce que Tik Tok
opère des censures sur un certain nombre
de sujets ou au contraire pousse des
sujets qui seraient susceptibles de
désinformation d'influence voire de
déstabilisation des systèmes
démocratiques comme on l'a vu au cours
des années passées avec d'autres
plateformes l'immense majorité de nos
auditions sont publiques peuvent être
suivies en direct sur le site internet
du scénariste et ce qui permet aux
citoyens finalement dont nous sommes les
portes-parole d'aller creuser avec nous
un sujet pour permettre d'éclairer à la
fois la représentation nationale et la
Nation toute entière